>From the home screen of T-Square,
start by clicking preferences.
The home screen here will let
you modify your active classes.
To remove a class from your active
sites list select the class
then click on the right arrow.
To show a class, select the class and
click the left arrow to add
it back to your active sites.
So let me go ahead and hide
the classes that I'm not currently in.
Then I'm going to click
update preferences.
Then once I refresh the page,
I will only see those two
courses at the top of the page.
So again, this won't remove your
access to the classes altogether.
This just toggles which
classes appear above.
You can always access any
class you've already taken by
clicking membership up here.
As you can see, here are all the classes
that I have taken at Georgia Tech.
>> Generally in the OMS program, you
probably won't take enough classes to
really need to worry about
hiding inactive classes.
But if you've done other degrees
in the past at Georgia Tech,
you might need to hide some of these.
My box is 82 classes, so
I definitely need to hide some.
>> So once you start the program,
you might receive more notifications
than what you would like to see.
Therefore, in order to tweak this,
you can go to the notifications
tab at the top.
Here, you can play with
some of these features and
opt in to receive only the messages
that you would like to receive.
So in my case, I only want to be updated
about new resources once per day.
So I would click here.
And then I would update
preferences here.
The most important one though,
is the ability to change your time zone.
This isn't a big deal to on-campus
students, but online, it's crucial.
We encourage most of our classes
to make their assignments
due at 12:00 AM UTC-12 time zone.
But it's hard to translate
that to your local time.
So even though I'm in Eastern time zone,
let's pretend I'm in Pacific.
I would then select Pacific and
then I would update preferences.
So now that I've switched
over to Pacific time zone,
all of my assignments show that
they are due at 5 AM Pacific time.
We'll talk more about
the assignment screen in a bit.
>> That covers the settings that
affect T-Square as a whole.
Any change you make here will affect
every class you're currently in in
T-Square.
So now let's take a look at
some of the tools that apply to
only individual classes.